يعني ما ان اعلنت الولايات المتحده انها
اعادت ادراج جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين
على قائمه الارهاب حتى قامت الجماعه من
جديد باستهداف سفينه امريكيه ما الرساله
التي يجدر على الولايات المتحده ان تقراها
من وراء ذلك ا خليني اوضح نقطه مهمه اداره
بايدن لم تعيد تصنيف الحوثيين منظمه
ارهابيه ام اعادت تصنيفهم منظمه مجموعه
ارهابيه
خاصه وليس منظمه ارهاب يعني في تلاعب
بالكلام ان العصا والجزره اذا توقفت عن
القصف و
يعني لم تعوا تشكلوا خطر لتهديد الملاحه
العالميه فسن فع عنكم هذا التصنيف المؤقت
الفارق ويبدا هو بعد 30 يوم الفارق بان اف
تي او فورن ترست اورجانيزيشن يصنف منظمه
ارهابيه مثل حماس مثل الجهاد الاسلامي مثل
حزب الله هذه المنظمه ارهابيه مصنفه
الحوثيين سبيشال ديجنت رر جلوبال ترر
اورجانيزيشن اللي هي بين المنظمه
الارهابيه الكامله وبين المنظمه الارهابيه
المؤقته ويبدا هذا بعد شهر من الان وطبعا
لما يصنف منظمه ارهابيه يعني لا يمكن
التعاون معه لا يمكن السماح بارسال
مساعدات
غذائيه ادويه وغيرها من المساعدات
الانسانيه وطبعا الامريكان يحاولون ان
يفصلوا طبعا هذا كلام مو صحيح او غير
واقعي الفصل بين معاقبه الحوثييين على
تهديدهم الملاحه العالميه والاقتصاد
العالمي وبين الشعب اليمني الذي هو صار له
الحين يعني عقد من الزمن في وضع بائس وهذا
تخبط امريكي جديد يعني اذكر هني في ايام
الاخيره للرئيس ترامب في يناير
2021 صنف الحوثيين منظمه ارهابيه ثم اعا
بعد شهر عندما اتى بايدن رفع لان طبعا
تكلم عن موضوع المساعدات الانسانيه ولما
نصنف الحوثييين لا يمكن ان نصل لهم اغاثه
مساعدا رساله الحوثيين جماعه انصار الله
الحوثيين من وراء استهداف سفينه امريكيه
فورا بعد هذا الص طبعا هذه رساله تحدي
وهذا كان متوقع امريكا لن تستطيع ان توقف
الحوثيين فشلت امريكا في وقف جميع
التنظيمات غير من غير الدول يعني حزب الله
وحماس والجهاد الاسلامي لا يزالوا يقومون
بعمليات رغم تصنيفهم منظمات ارهابيه فلا
يمكن ان تنتصر يعني امريكا لم تهزم
القاعده ولم تهزم داعش ولم تهزم طالبان
لان هذه حروب غير متناظره بين جيوش نظاميه
وبين جماعات مواليه او عندها عقيده او
عندها فكر ولا يمكنك ان تهزمهم الان في
اللعبه كلها هذه ايران هي اللاعب الرئيسي
وهي التي طبعا كل هذه رسائل من امريكا
بشكل غير مباشر الى ايران ايران قاعده
تصعد الان بشكل غير مسبوق يعني خلال 24
ساعه من من يومين تقريبا قصفت اربيل
وقصفت داعش في سوريا وقصفت باكستان واليوم
باكستان تغلق الحدود وتستدعي السفير و وفي
تطورات متلاحقه رايك دكتور بما قاله جيك
سليفن مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي ان
واشنطن ان واشنطن تريد ان يجبر هذا
التصنيف الحوثيين على الابتعاد عن ايران
ما واقعيه هذا الت كلام فاضي يعني تخب
يعني ش تبعدهم عن ايران والحليف الرئيسي
والممول يعني القوه المهمه للحوثيين هي من
ايران فلا كيف يمكن لما نضعهم او نهدم
بوضع على قائمه المنظمات الارهابيه الخاصه
وليس المنظمات الارهابيه الدائمه بانك انت
ستبعده عن ايران والرد اتى مبكرا انتم
سويتوا مقابله مع محمد عبد السلام الناطق
باسم الحوثيين وكان واضح جدا نبره التحدي
وسنستمر يعني هو اللف والدوران هذا متعب
اداره بايدن بالفعل
تتخبط الحل الاسهل والاقصر ضغط على
اسرائيل لوقف الحرب والحرب الدمار
والاباده في غزه لان الحوثين يستخدمون
ورقه دعم المقاومه ضعم حماس في غزه وقالها
اليوم قبل قليل يحيى السريع الناطق باسم
الحوثيين باننا نحن سنستمر باستهداف السفن
البريطانيه والامريكيه والمتجه الى ايلات
واسرائيل والسفن الاسرائيليه طالما لم
توقف الحرب ولم يرفع الحصار طيب ولكن هذا
التصنيف اليوم وكما وضحته لنا دكتور اي
انعكاس سيكون له اولا على البنيه التحتيه
العسكريه للحوثيين وثانيا ايضا على الشعب
اليمني طبعا سيكون له مضاعفات خطيره بعد
شهر من الان اذا استمر على البنيه التحتيه
القتاليه للحوثيين تاثرت الامريكان
يعترفون تاثرت ب 30% فقط فالحوثيون لن
يتوقفوا سيستمر بالتحدي سيرسل رسائل واضحه
سواء بالتصريحات او سواء بالمزيد من
استهداف السفن وناقلات النفط الاقتصاد
العالمي يعاني الان معظم الشركات الكبرى
في الحاويات قاعده تنتقل الى تقريبا 6000
م زياده تذهب الى راس الرجاء الصالح تلف
كل افريقيا لتذهب الى اوروبا مما يؤخر
وصول الامدادات وايضا يزيد من اسعار الشحن
واسعار ايضا التامين على السفن فالوضع
يعني ملتهب والمنطقه على ما يبدو تقترب من
غليان سواء في جبهه جنوب لبنان او جوا في
باكستان وايران او سواء باستمرار الحرب في
غزه يعني اداره بايدن اذا بالفعل تب تلعب
دور ايجابي لوقف التصعيد بدلا من الكلام
الانشائي والتخبط
والتناقضات تفرض على اسرائيل وقف العمليات
العسكريه وحرب الاباده في غزه مما ينزع
الفكيه من كل هذه
الملفات ان هذا هو التوجه حتى الان لا
يبدو ان هذا هو التوجه حتى الان وبالتالي
هذا التصنيف كذلك لجماعه انصار ل الحوثيين
بعد ان كان رفعهم عن قائمه الارهاب مقدمه
ربما لحلح الامور الان اعاده وضعهم او
تصنيفهم بالتصنيف الجديد نعم اي انعكاس
سيكون له على المنطقه
عموما المنطقه تتجه الى نوع من الاحتقان
انا في اعتقادي والسبب طبعا هو طبعا
التناقض الامريكي ان بايدن يقول ولما اتى
بلينكن الاسبوع الماضي يريد ان يمنع
الانفجار وتوسع رقعه القتال والحرب من غزه
وحزب وحماس ولبنان الى ان يكون هناك في
احتواء لهذه الازمه او لهذه الحرب او حرب
الاباده وخاصه بعد قرار او بعد استماع
محكمه العدل الدوليه
لمرافعة اليوم هليفي اللي هو الناطق باسم
وزاره باسم الدفاع
الاسرائيلي يقول بان نقترب اكثر اليوم من
مواجهه مع حزب الله في في جنوب لبنان اكثر
من اي وقت مضى ولكن لا نعلم ماذا سيحدث في
تصعيد في في غليان مع غزه يوجد لا يزال
الوضع مستمر الان دخل على المعادله
الحوثيون والتصعيد ودخلت ايضا ايران مع
باكستان وايران مع العراق الان الجامعه
العربيه قد يجتمع المندوبين ويندد بالقصف
على اربيل هناك ايضا مطالبات ب ادانه
ايران بالنسبه لقصفها لداخل باكستان
فالامور يعني بالفعل قع تغلي ونامل يعني
ان يكون هناك في عقلانيه عند الاداره
الامريكيه للعب دور اكثر ايجابيه لوقف كل
هذا التصعيد ونزع فتيل للانفجار اشكرك
دكتور عبد الله الشايجي استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه الكويت ضيفنا هنا في
الاستديو شكرا